air pollution is the single biggest
environmental threat to the health and
well-being of people around the world
that's according to the world health
organization in 2019 more than a million
people across africa were killed from
air pollution it's the second leading
cause of death across the continent
after aids
african cities regularly break
international guidelines for safe levels
of pollutants in the air
pollution levels in uganda's capital
kampala are up to seven times higher
than the who recommends
ugandan climate activist hilda
nacabriere is concerned about the air
quality in her city
the smoke from burning waste
traffic fumes and industrial remissions
have made kampala one of africa's most
polluted cities
the air here feels
very unclean very polluted it feels
choking there's
a sudden change in smell that you can
feel
it doesn't feel healthy at all
nakawia runs ugandan group of the
climate change movement fridays for
future
she is known for speaking up for the
environment but now she is taking action
makawii wants to sue the city
authorities
she accuses them of failing to combat
air pollution
she interviews asthma sufferer diana
naviruma as a potential witness
i have allergy induced asthma
that means that
if i wasn't reacting to substances in
the air i wouldn't be asthmatic i wasn't
born with asthma
i grew up a normal child
hospitals are seeing an increase in
illnesses linked to breathing bad air
such as lung cancer and asthma
from our data
the prevalence of asthma in uganda is
about 12 percent this is about four
percentage points uh i had the general
average for africa actually
and the burden actually is very high
for example when you take these asthma
11 percent of 45 million these are a lot
of people
and we have done studies actually when
you you get a hundred a thousand
asthmatics
okay and follow them for one year what
we call a thousand person years twenty
seven of them will die in a year
nakawia wants the city authorities to do
more to tackle the problem
well they have the power to regulate the
amount of cars that are coming in and
out of the city that are contributing so
much to the air pollution i feel like
there should be more trees on the
roadside like we see in other cities
abroad that help in cleaning up the air
i feel that
there's an issue with our waste damping
sorting and collection and that needs to
be checked
but the authorities say that they don't
have the money to clean up the city's
air
one of the biggest problems kampala is
lacking is funding
the government of uganda supported us
very well and we are very very thankful
but the big plans we have
require big funding
and that's why i call upon
the development partners
to also come in and support
uganda has taken some steps to help
reduce air pollution
it has burned the import of older less
environmentally friendly cars
and authorities plan to expand public
transport to help decongest the city
but the problem of emissions remains
from factory fumes to widespread burning
of waste
until these key policies are effectively
addressed nakawia says that kampla's air
is unlikely to get any cleaner
and researchers agree with hilda
nakabuya's claims they say now is the
time for cities across africa to act and
opt for cleaner energy but many have a
long way to go the 2021 wealth air
quality report found germanna in chat to
be the most polluted city on the
continent in the previous five years
chad's capital exceeded the who's
guidelines for safe air limits by more
than 10 times
gemina is closely followed by nigeria's
main oil refining city port harcourt and
residents of sudan's capital hartoum are
being told to keep their windows closed
and wear a mask when they go outside
let's talk more about air pollution
across africa with edmond san ganado
environmental scientist at northumbria
university in newcastle hello and
welcome sir now some of the most air
polluted countries come as no surprise
but how did in germany in chat become
the worst air polluted city in africa
if air pollution occurs in two ways
there is you know inside our houses and
outside inside our houses is mainly
because when you
the things that we use for cooking and
eating you know so when you use wood and
charcoal it releases suit which is going
to affect human health then outside is
mainly transport and other things now in
chad
two houses out of hundreds have access
to electricity that leaves 15.6
million people who rely on wood and
charcoal and this has got some serious
consequences on health
yeah that's uh sounds staggering now we
know that air pollution killed at least
one million people across africa in 2019
you've said before that if it is not
addressed results would be catastrophic
how much more catastrophic could it get
did you know
ghana ethiopia and rwanda in 2019 alone
they lost more than five billion due to
premature deaths and hospitalization
that's twice the gdp of burundi and half
the gdp of child but economists can
recover
what cannot be recovered is the two
point
two two billion iq points that were
wiped out by air pollution from our
children in 2019 and on
so i mean
clearly something should be done about
it what can authorities do
so
like i mentioned about our cue points
you can see that uh air pollution
doesn't affect health only it also
affects yoga it affects energy it
affects transport and fixed housing
environment in the workforce so there
are different departments that are in
charge of addressing issues concerning
these seven issues right so these
departments need to work together and
come up with clear and coin policies
that protect citizens from air pollution
and the second thing is we need to have
better infrastructure for accessing
electricity right so as we have seen in
the case of child that poor access is
affecting uh air pollution so those are
the two main things that we really need
to address
well let me ask this
in uganda for example researchers have
developed and installed low-cost air
quality monitors in schools and other
areas to help address air pollution is
that a way to go
yes because uh you'll find like the
whole of africa i think they are
i think only seven countries have got
national air quality monitoring out of
54 countries that is really
that's a terrible situation that we
don't really know the extent of the
problem
so the the innovations that are coming
out of uganda they are going to help the
whole continent so that we can know what
is the situation at community level and
national level
the normal argument has been that it is
expensive to tackle air pollution but
you see nature-based mitigation
strategies are viable alternatives tell
us more about these alternatives
so technology is not always the silver
bullet to address all problems sometimes
it's the simplest like planting trees
planting flowers having trees on the
roofs you know when we create green
spaces we don't only beautify our cities
but we can also help clean the air so
those are kind of the ways that we can
use
okay now away from the role of
authorities what can someone like me do
to contribute to a cleaner air
so the first thing that i would really
recommend is we need to move away from
using wood and charcoal for heating and
cooking right try to use uh
clean up yours like biogas natural gas
right well guys you can actually
generate if you're from the village you
avoid agricultural waste you can
actually make biogas from that you can
also need to buy things more cheaper air
quality monitors i think they cost about
30 dollars then
again our emphasize plant trees grow
flowers in your house because sometimes
the beautiful things are the best
solutions
okay nice way to wrap that up edmond san
ganado environmental scientist thanks
for your time
now to breathe cleaner air we need less
pollution right as we've heard traffic
congestion is contributing to poor air
quality across africa but some people
are trying to make a change let's take
you to lagos in nigeria africa's most
populous city and certainly one of the
continents nightmares when it comes to
traffic meet the woman who's choosing to
ride two wheels rather than four
beating the rush hour traffic in lagos
drivers might be stuck in motorist
misery but cyclist asia fakaku zifi
wokolo zips past them on her way to work
she says the benefits of riding a
bicycle outweigh the dangers
one of the main reasons is
just getting to places a bit quicker
so there's a lot of traffic
there's no rail yet so what's the next
best option apart from walking or
running which will get you there quickly
and cycling
at least it's faster than being in
traffic
ziffy is one of a growing number of
bicycle enthusiasts in lagos
on weekends she rides for fun and
fitness with her club cyclotron
and as vice president she encourages
other younger riders to get on their
bikes
sifi is an inspiration to even men a lot
of guys cannot do what if he can do
she's got the legs he's good riding is
fun riding is enjoyable it's a good
workout it bonds with everything so i
recommend it for everyone who is not
currently riding
ziffy says cycling could be part of the
solution to lagos transport worlds
people are beginning to
embrace it the idea it's free one right
yo there's no cost of
we're not polluting the environment and
the health benefits
also as well so yes
there are more people
[Applause]
with zifi leading the way on her bicycle
she's setting an example
pushing for cycling as an alternative in
one of africa's busiest cities
you